moi ça
[Musique]
chaque chroniqueur papa de tous les
produits comme ce qu on va pas faire non
plus deux heures vérité de l'amour mais
certains chroniqueurs vont jouer avec un
défi j'en ferai également
je vous le dis pour faire gagner un
magnifique cadeau à quelqu'un qui est au
téléphone
d'accord même si rim on juge que tu vas
avoir une minute pas plus on aura les
familles pour toi ça va être très simple
franchement c'est plutôt simple tu vas
avoir une minute pour trouver une
personne et danser avec elle sur un
poteau mais de façon très sexy
ah oui un poteau dans la rue là ok ok on
peut toujours changer
[Applaudissements]
village en deux j'adore tjr si beaucoup
c'est très simple tu vas voir une minute
pour trouver une personne en voitures
allait lui offrir des fleurs et demander
un petit bisou en retour enfin c'est
quoi la limite tu vas jouer pour un
casque de réalité virtuelle
j'ai pas de fumée pas fois là bas tu en
voilà
et donc j'arrête une voiture n'importe
quel nom
[Applaudissements]
bof pas de voiture à temps de faire
enfin voiture avait été placée à bochum
hasarde à ivato meriem ayasse et un
cousin en plus sa cousine
c'est pourtant faux a même s'ils ne la
regarde pas qui était assis là tu es la
sortie j'ai gagné deux cousins
[Applaudissements]
valérie c'est très simple vous allez
devoir partir ouais ah bon vous allez
avoir exactement un mois pour trouver
notre galerie photos sont toujours mal
au match uruguay et autres ans qui
déclare qu elle s'enfuit alors valérie
tu vas voir une minute tu vas jouer on
va jouer pour une machine à café
bidart match il a cassé la gueule tu vas
voir une minute pour aller faire une
déclaration d'amour à un inconnu
enfin surtout pour quelqu'un que je suis
sur les chars attention va pas de fonds
non on le connaît non non le déni que le
feu n'est pas laissée là attention fais
attention tu me fais peur sur la route
comme voilà la regarde se voulait
simplement universelle je vous ai vus
régulièrement je suis le fils de studio
il est beau gosse est en fait
assure-t-elle
je me disais que ben vous aviez vraiment
la tête du content de charme que il est
beau gosse soit le plus beau des
couscous est vraiment vous étiez voilà
une petite boulette
non je voulais faire partie à votre tour
vous étiez un mois les camés charme de
cette déclaration parce que vous êtes
sous le charme
proposent leur show de syrie j'aimerais
ce que je fais ce que je peux rattraper
la métaphore avec un stylo un slow wear
un petit seconde année ouais
[Applaudissements]
il s'appelle jonathan il est pas mal du
tout walgreen a zappé chaud dans les
réseaux c'est très simple vous allez
avoir
vous avez joué avec maxime gagny pour
une console de jeu portable ou là tu vas
voir une minute pour trouver une
personne lui demander son prénom et le
crier de plaisir comme si vous faisiez
l'amour avec lui ouais d'accord si
d'accord c'est madame web bruisse plus
vous demander votre prénom kalala ici
malisse et marie cécile marie cécile au
mieux mon cas la demi amarrée ccc je
t'aime d'accord darfour tamouls
ça compte a demandé mais qu'est ce qui
l'a qui sera close à l'instant ça va
qu'est ce que cela vous fait il te fait
quoi
mais quand il faisait l'amour c'est
gratuit il connaît pas ça au cecil a
autrefois demandé de chanter normal
marie cécile beziat les os il est comme
ça quelle amertume tueur est dehors pour
l'instant ça n'est pas gagné
tant que c'est pas satisfaisant c'est
peut-être secure est de 12 mais c'est
refera des orgasmes jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission
[Musique]